Speaker 1: Let's talk about Ron DeSantis.
Let's talk about the 2024 primary, the biggest
signal yet that Ron DeSantis plans to run
for president in 2024, regardless of whether
Trump is a candidate, is that DeSantis is
now holding fundraisers with Republican mega-donors.
And it's very clear what the plan is here.
I mentioned this yesterday, and I said we
would delve into it more deeply today if the
Republican mega-donors say to de Santos, if
you run in 24, we will support you rather
than Trump.
That gives DeSantis the confidence to go up
against Trump in a contested primary.
One of the things that has infuriated Trump
about DeSantis is that over the last year,
when asked, Would you only run if Trump doesn't,
will you rule out a run if Trump does want
the nomination?
DeSantis has declined to make that promise.
He's just said, I just haven't made a decision
yet.
I haven't.
I haven't decided yet.
And now DeSantis is doing a major fundraiser.
CNBC Reporting Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
Plans Utah Fundraiser with Republican Megadonor.
Signaling possible presidential run.
Yeah, you you do that if you're thinking of
running for president.
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is planning
a private fundraiser in Utah with some of
the country's wealthiest Republican donors.
DeSantis hasn't publicly ruled out a run for
president in 24, even if it means challenging
Trump.
DeSantis spokeswoman Lindsay Cronut wouldn't
confirm any details, saying the campaign doesn't
discuss private fundraising events with members
of the press.
This is going to be next week, the week of
July 18th.
Many of the attendees asked not to be identified
because the campaign is trying to keep the
private event from getting too much public
attention.
The Santas is coming to Utah to raise money
for his 2022 gubernatorial reelection campaign.
Fundraisers in far flung states like Utah,
more than 2000 miles from Florida, where this
is actually a candidate right now, often suggest
nature, national aspirations.
So the next question is, what does the polling
look like?
DeSantis hasn't said he's running and Trump
hasn't said that he's running.
Well, we have recent data polling, Republican
primary polling, and it sort of looks okay
for Ron DeSantis considering he hasn't announced
anything yet.
Polls on morning consult from a few days ago.
Trump 52.
DeSantis 21.
Now understand.
Trump's up throw.
DeSantis is not a former president.
DeSantis is not nearly as well-known as Trump,
not even not even marginally as well-known
as Trump.
And DeSantis hasn't announced anything, and
he's already polling 21% from a few days prior.
New York Times Siena College poll has DeSantis
with 25% against Trump plus 24 a few days
earlier.
The courageous Conservatives PAC poll has
a lot of undecideds and other candidates,
but has Trump 38, DeSantis 17.
That's only a 21 point margin for DeSantis.
And then a poll at the end of June as well
from Harvard University.
Harris.
DeSantis doing significantly better than Pence,
despite Pence being the former vice president.
So that's interesting.
The polling numbers don't look bad for DeSantis,
despite the centers having taken no moves
yet.
And then maybe more importantly, at this early
stage, when you allow people to bet money
on who they believe will be the nominee.
Sometimes you get more forward looking data
or information.
And if you look at the betting markets right
now, there is only a seven cent difference.
And I'll explain what that means between Donald
Trump and Ron DeSantis.
This is not who will you support.
This is BET money.
Who will win the 2024 Republican presidential
nomination?
When it comes to Trump, you have to bet $0.42
to make a dollar.
And when it comes to Ron DeSantis, you have
to bet $0.35 to make a dollar.
That means it is seen as only slightly less
likely that DeSantis will be the nominee than
Trump.
Those are incredible numbers this far out,
particularly considering that de Santos hasn't
announced anything.
Now, Trump hasn't either.
But as I said, Trump is much more well-known.
And Donald Trump also is talking about running
in a way that that Ron DeSantis isn't also
relevant.
Nobody else is even in the picture.
I mean, you've got Nikki Haley Pence, Glenn
Youngkin, Mike Pompeo, Ted Cruz, Tim Scott,
just pennies, pennies, pennies on the dollar.
So the truth is, if DeSantis wants this, it's
not a guarantee that he could win, but he
will be a player for sure.
And if he gets that Republican mega-donor
support, if the Republican mega-donors kind
of give him the old wink wink and say, if
you were to run.
We would be eager to support an alternative
to what we've done in the past.
I think the Santos is very, very well positioned.